هذه الدبابه هي احدث دبابه تخدم في القوات
الروسيه بفتره خدمه لم تتجاوز السنتين كما
تعد افضل دبابه عامله في روسيا في الوقت
الحالي تعد النسخه المحادثه من دبابه تي
90 والتي دخلت الخدمه في اوائل التسعينيات
القرن الماضي بدا ظهور الدبابه في ساحه
المعارك في اوكرانيا بعد شهرين فقط من بدء
العمليه العسكريه روسيه في اوكرانيا
تكتيك العزل الحراري الذي تتمتع به هذه
الدبابه ايضا يعيق وصول الصواريخ الحراريه
اليها كما انها مزوده بنظام حمايه نشط هذا
النظام يستطيع رصد الصواريخ المتجهه نحو
الدبابه واطلاق مقذوفات صغيره لا اعتراضها
الدبابه تتمتع ايضا بمستوى تدريع قوي
القوات الروسيه تقول انه مصنع من ماده
خاصه يمنح الدبابه حمايه فائقه من قذائف
الدبابات المواجهه
[موسيقى]
حيث تم رصد تدمير عدد كبير من هذه
الدبابات في الحربه يعتقد انها تعاني مما
تعاني منها دبابات روسيه اخرى حيث تعاني
من موقع تخزين الذخائر في اسفل ومحيط
البرج وهو ما يعرضها للتحطم في حال حدوث
اي اختراق لهيكل هذه الدبابه
[موسيقى]